Wolfgang powley was one of the most
brilliant physicists of his time but he
was also Savage in his criticism happy
to use his considerable witch to tear
apart ideas or theories he thought
lacking he took to signing off his
letters with the title D Gaisor goddess
German for the scourge of God but
perhaps most famously he once solemnly
responded to a young physicist's Earnest
paper with a simple but brutal epithet
that the offending work was not even
wrong
although not all ideas have a powerly to
puncture them most scientific theories
do end up dead and forgotten most
scientific theories
fail they may have had their day they
may have been widely believed the focus
of papers seminars and conferences only
to end up a footnote in the history
books
[Music]
once upon a time it was thought that
something called flow giston existed
residing inside objects it was released
when they were burned during the 18th
century the theory of logistan was one
of the foremost explanations for heat
and combustion professors taught it
students learned it and the chemists of
the day attempted to interpret their
results with it but the idea very simply
was wrong the flow just an account of
heat was a fantasy the truth as we now
know lay in chemistry and the
combination of different elements in
various chemical reactions somewhere at
some point in history the last believer
in the flo Justin theory of heat died
in the mid-20th century there were two
competing ideas for understanding the
origin of matter in the universe one was
the Big Bang Theory the idea that the
cosmos was once extremely small dense
and hot and then expanded into the vast
Cosmic structures we observed today but
there was also another competing Theory
the so-called steady state theory in
which Mata was constantly being created
to sustain the universe so that it
remained on large scales
eternally the same at one time the
steady state theory was one of the most
discussed ideas in astrophysics and
cosmology even Einstein had an interest
in it but over the years evidence piled
up in favor of the big bang and with the
discovery of hugely powerful quasars at
cosmological distances which dated from
the younger universe and have no
counterparts today gradually the lights
went out for steady state the last
Conference was held the last talks were
given and the last adherence of the idea
tired leaving only filing cabinets
packed with old yellowing notes
and so we arrive to the present day and
the ongoing quest for a fundamental
theory that explains everything within
our universe the quest to unite the two
pillars of general relativity and
quantum mechanics our current leading
Frameworks for quantum gravity are known
as string theory and M Theory ideas
which claim extra dimensions and Tiny
vibrating strings exist deep within
everything at the as yet unobserved
heart of nature or even vast
multi-dimensional brains stretched
across an imperceivable bulk many many
physicists and mathematicians are
working on these cutting-edge ideas
regular conferences are being held
packed with both young and old all
chasing the Holy Grail of physics a
unified theory that explains it all
will these theories last do they really
represent viable solutions to the
fundamental questions of the universe or
tragically misled Community lost in
elegant mathematics with no hope of
finding connections to the real world
let alone a shred of testable evidence
will one day string and M Theory too be
found as Dusty footnotes in fading tones
are they as Paulie wants mused
not even wrong
this year's Nobel Prize in physics was
awarded for Research into quantum
entanglement leading to deep questions
about whether our universe is even
locally real unfortunately for
controlling our devices our macroscopic
world does appear to have different
locations this is where our sponsor any
desk comes in the best remote desktop
software on the market helping you
access any device anywhere anytime from
it support to easily working at home
from Super straightforward file transfer
to controlling everything with just your
mobile any desk is a secure and fast way
to stay on top of things wherever you
are on Earth but not if you were light
years away it is also easily
customizable and smoothly runs on all
major operating systems and most
importantly it's very simple and
straightforward to use so try it out for
yourself at anydesk.com they have a
great free version for non-business
users thanks to any desk for supporting
educational content on YouTube
what is meant by fundamental
push distances inwards start with us
bipedal members of Homo Sapien sapiens
normally standing a bit over one and a
half meters focus our view narrower and
narrower first the scale of insects
little creepy crawly objects one
centimeter across a factor of 100 next
head down to the size of cells the
powerhouses of human metabolism that
brings us down by another factor of ten
thousand reaching micrometers we go
again another scaling down by a factor
of a thousand brings us first to
molecules and then to atoms and the
quantum mechanical bonds of electrons in
orbitals that hold atoms together to
form the building blocks of life where
now distances slightly less than one
billionth of a meter where quantum
mechanics rules if we were to look
around in a little Cube one billionth of
a meter across then the number of such
cubes that would fit inside our body is
greater than the number of stars in the
observable universe and yet this is only
the start of our inwards journey at the
center of atoms lies the nucleus the
radius of the nucleus 100
000 times smaller than the size of the
atom itself the nuclear ball consists of
protons and neutrons little clumps of
quarks both held together by the strong
nuclear force and also attracted to each
other by the strong nuclear force we're
now at distances of one fentometer one
million billionth of a meter and
entering the realm of particle physics
particle colliders are our world's most
powerful microscopes using these and in
particular the Large Hadron Collider we
are able to probe inwards by an extra
factor of one thousand to picometers
but no more
the realm Beyond this is the realm of
theory
where we would continue to go in a
deeper and further until we reach the
scales on which our ordinary classical
Notions of space and time break down and
must be replaced by some quantum
mechanical replacement for the classical
theory of space-time described by
Einstein's theory of relativity
calculations suggest that this would
occur at a distance of 1 million
billionth of a picometer where quantum
gravity will take over and it is at this
distance scale we perhaps reach the
scale of strings
relativistic quantum mechanical strings
that some physicists say may be the most
fundamental building blocks of the
universe what everything is truly made
of
and yet surprisingly this idea String
Theory did not start off as a potential
fundamental theory of nature to climb
back up the ladder at distant scales of
around a femtometer only one million
billionth of a meter we are in the realm
of the strong force the strong force
which at one point many people believed
was actually a string Force
String Theory started its life in the
summer of 1968 as a possible theory of
the strong nuclear force a candidate to
explain the forces and interactions that
hold protons and neutrons together the
first paper on string theory arrived in
Berkeley in the summer of 1968. everyone
had stopped what they were doing and
were asking if this idea could be
extended however it did not turn out to
be a success in this String Theory
account of the strong force the internal
structure of protons and neutrons
involved strings not particles this made
a clear prediction when launched towards
each other at high energies these
particles would slop off each other like
balls of jelly and not bounce like hard
billiard balls and so in the early 1970s
these experiments were carried out and
careful measurements revealed that the
number of these hard scattering events
was far far in excess of what was
predicted by the string theory of the
strong nuclear force as a theory of the
strong nuclear force String Theory died
in 1973 to be replaced by the correct
theory of quantum chromodynamics
[Music]
but in theoretical physics sometimes
death is only the Prelude to
Resurrection
some felt that there was something too
neat about the calculations in string
theory beautiful features that had no
obvious reason to be present and yet
were and so throughout the 1970s some
physicists notably John Schwartz of
Caltech and Michael Green of Queen Mary
in London continued to develop String
Theory not as a quantum theory of the
strong nuclear force but as a potential
quantum theory of gravity itself many
times it seemed that the theory was on
the verge of failing of being ruled out
as simply inconsistent with the laws of
quantum mechanics it only seemed to work
where there were precisely nine
dimensions of space neither more nor
less but then always there was a way
through that made the theory appear ever
more unique during the 1980s String
Theory became established as the leading
candidate for a quantum theory that
would include gravity a theory where you
could put both gravity and forces like
electromagnetism together in harmony for
the first time
perhaps some dared to dream in proud and
Foolish Dreams all aspects of particle
physics would be uniquely singled out
everything could be predicted with
strings
[Music]
however by the late 1980s one aspect of
string theory appeared odd it had been
touted as the theory at least in
universes with 10 flat space-time
Dimensions the singular answer to all of
the problems of particle physics the
only problem was that there was not just
one string theory which existed in 10
Dimensions there were five of them the
type 2A String Theory the type 2 B
Theory two type 1 theories and finally
something called the heterotic string
theory theories all had slight
differences both the type 2 theories and
also the heterotic theory were what is
called closed string theories all the
strings involved will close Loops
reaching back on themselves like elastic
bands they had no ends between
themselves the internal dynamics of
these three theories also differ
slightly the strings in each case
behaved in different ways the type 1
theories also included closed strings
but in addition open strings these were
not closed but instead had end points
vibrating at the speed of light like a
perpetually cracking whip the open and
close strings differed in their
interactions while the closed strings
behaved more like Gravity the open
strings behaved like generalization of
the electromagnetic weak and strong
forces and so
five five is not a large number however
it posed a puzzle five is not one to any
ambitious possibly arrogant physicist
hoping that string theory might be the
unique Theory even two would have been
one too large given the existence of
five consistent theories what singled
out one of these five theories as
opposed to any of the others as the
chosen one
the presence of five different theories
did not imply that each Theory only had
one solution in the same way that our
ordinary theory of gravity contains as a
solution both a single lonely Rock
flying through space and the full
complexities of our solar system with
satellites orbiting moons orbiting
planets orbiting the Sun so each of
these five string theories admitted many
many different possible solutions for
their equations there may have only been
five possible sets of fundamental
equations but the number of solutions
was effectively unbounded but still in
terms of the fundamental equations there
appeared to be five choices
and five is not the same as one
[Music]
in an ancient Indian Parable an elephant
wanders into a town where a group of
blind men are sitting the Blind Men can
hear the Beast and decide that they need
to touch it to get a sense of what it is
one places his hand on the trunk which
is around and feels along it I know he
announces the being is a type of snake
another man touches one of the
elephant's legs and feels how large and
strong they are no he says this is a
kind of walking tree trunk a third man
finds his hand on the Tusk hard long and
sharp you are both wrong he says this is
a moving War Machine each could feel one
part of the animal but none of them
could see the coherent Mega animal that
is the elephant
viewed from today the physicists of the
1980s studying five string theories are
like the blind townsfolk touching the
elephant and that is because today we
think of each of these five theories as
different limits different boundaries of
a single underlying object one both
deeper and more mysterious not an
elephant but M Theory and whether m
stands for mystery magic or something
else has been left open to
interpretation
of course the idea that five similar but
different string theories were actually
aspects of one single hole would have
appeared bizarre and surprising that is
until Edward Whitton spoke at the 1995
strings conference
Edward Whitton is the physicist who
almost never was widely regarded as the
premier mathematical physicist of his
generation his undergraduate degree was
in history after briefly assisting on
the 1968 McGovern presidential campaign
he decided that his principal interest
to lay in the Sciences still unsure that
he would be able to catch up he
initially applied to do Graduate Studies
in economics fortunately Princeton saw
through his background to detect the
innate talent and took him on as a
graduate student in theoretical physics
theoretical physics and pure mathematics
are two subjects divided by a Common
Language although both use similar
notation their ways of thinking and
standards of rigor are very different to
a mathematician physicists are
frustratingly sloppy with a fundamental
inability to give precise definitions to
physicists mathematicians are so
obsessed with rigor and proving results
that are obvious they can never address
problems that actually matter witton's
great gift was that he was fluent in
both languages and Rose to prominence at
a time when the interface between
physics and Mathematics had been long
neglected he reignited the relationship
using Quantum field Theory and string
theory to draw many deep connections
between the two subjects resulting in
him becoming the first physicist to win
the fields medal the premiere prize in
mathematics
and so by 1995 a long list of
discoveries had turned Whitten into the
person everybody wanted to hear
as participants finished their welcome
coffee and settled down for the 9am talk
on the 14th of March at the 1995 strings
conference some of them had an inkling
that they were about to witness
something special but as Whitten got up
and began talking the audience soon
realized that this was something truly
Monumental for he was describing a
wholly new map of string theory there
were not Whitton claimed actually five
fundamental theories but really only one
and the five string theories and one
extra non-string Theory called
supergravity should be viewed as being
on the boundary of one even more
fundamental M Theory this one theory was
continuously connected through a
mysterious interior in the same way that
flourishing coastal cities like Perth
Darwin Adelaide and Sydney are all part
of the single continent of Australia
filled with a large interior desert the
path through the interior may be
difficult and complicated but it does
exist and joins these boundary cities
together indeed the m in M Theory didn't
stand for anything in particular but had
been chosen as a placeholder of sorts
the word beginning with m to be finally
decided in the future when more about
the theory revealed itself
and what was more said Whitton M Theory
was 11 dimensional not 10 and the
fundamental objects of this
11-dimensional Theory were no longer
strings but a mysterious object taken
from super gravity the sixth Theory the
fundamental objects of M Theory were
brains
these were extended objects stretching
through more than one's spatial
Dimension when some of these spatial
Dimensions became very small the brains
could wrap around them and look like
strings and in these situations the
11-dimensional theory could in practice
be described as a string theory so for
10 years string theorists had been
working obsessively on a theory of
strings on string theory as the proposed
fundamental picture of Nature and now
the most dominant intellectual figure in
the subject was saying that it was not
strings but rather higher dimensional
objects called brains which really
mattered
but what were these mysterious brains
and how can we visualize them
start with a string a one-dimensional
object under tension a violin string or
wire a long thread at heart the strings
of string theory are just
one-dimensional extended objects and all
the physics from String Theory flows
from studying the relativistic quantum
mechanical theories of one-dimensional
extended objects moving and oscillating
their quantum mechanical relativistic
way through space a brain is basically a
version of this with more Dimensions the
name comes from membrane the
two-dimensional version a taut surface
think the skin of a drum the boundary of
a cell or the surface of a soap bubble a
two brain is an object extended through
two spatial dimensions a three brain
extended through three spatial
dimensions and so on a one brain is
simply a string while it is relatively
easy for us to visualize stretched
objects with one spatial Dimension or
two spatial Dimensions mathematics
happily extends this idea to even more
spatial dimensions for example the
equations can Define even if we cannot
visualize an object with four spatial
Dimensions extended within a space of
nine spatial dimensions and so the world
of M Theory Whitton told his audience
was one of 11 dimensions and with brains
not strings as the fundamental objects
different to lower energy limits of this
11-dimensional world in which one of the
dimensions became small produced the
five ten-dimensional string theories the
audience were already familiar with the
string theories that could be the
quantum gravity theories of our world in
these lower energy situations like our
universe the brains of M Theory in
particular something called the M2 brain
turn into the strings of 10-dimensional
string theories
but what does this all mean how can a
brain turn into a string as one
dimension becomes small what indeed does
it even mean for a dimension to become
small
there is no way to make this perfectly
intuitive but we can meet our intuition
part of the way how might extra
Dimensions be real but yet unobservable
one way to have a sense of this is to
imagine an insect walking on a plant
vine a Vine both long and thin an ant or
any other insect can walk along the vine
either forwards or backwards the surface
of the vines certainly has two
Dimensions zooming in with a powerful
microscope we would see the surface made
up of many cells stretching off in all
directions but the insect small though
it is is still too large to treat the
vine as having anything more than one
linear dimension in truth the surface of
the vine has two Dimensions but to a big
enough insect there is effectively only
a single Dimension as for the ant so too
perhaps for us if these extra dimensions
are small enough we and all our
technology are simply too big and too
clunky to resolve them like building
Lego with boxing gloves without tools
that probe such incredibly small
distances any structure on these
distances is simply inaccessible this is
believed to be the case for the extra
dimensions of string theory the extra
six spatial Dimensions wrapped up very
very small but M Theory takes this
counter-intuitive concept A step further
imagine a two-dimensional M brain an
incredibly high tension shrink wrapping
surface wrapped around a long thin wire
objects under tension want to shrink and
fold up think of the spandex material of
a morph suit this is a two-dimensional
stretched object which is under tension
and has a natural tendency to shrink its
surface area so that it tightly wraps
the object which defines the boundaries
in this case the Hume inside it and so
the extreme tension of the brain shrinks
it down and wraps itself around the wire
effectively turning it into a
one-dimensional object
and much of the connection of M Theory
to string theory relies on this idea
brains wrapping around small Dimensions
thus becoming lower dimensional objects
objects which would in string theory
ultimately make up but a fundamental
level the world we experience
where one of the 11 dimensions of M
Theory becomes very small much smaller
than any of the other dimensions the
one-dimensional strings of string theory
would emerge from the truly fundamental
two-dimensional brains of M Theory in
part by wrapping around the small extra
11th Dimension thus becoming
one-dimensional indeed all five string
theories emerged as various limits of
11-dimensional M Theory with one small
Dimension our universe would
hypothetically exist on one of the low
energy boundaries of this mysterious M
Theory a world of strings born from
wrapping higher dimensional brains
around minuscule extra dimensions
and so on that California morning in
1995 a new view of string theory
appeared out of the Mist one in which
even the strings themselves were not
fundamental objects arising as they did
from another even more fundamental
object
mathematically this was remarkable
but what did it mean for reality could
the brains of M Theory ever really make
predictions about our world a hot big
bang and expanding Universe full of
majestic galaxies
[Music]
when you look closely at the surface of
a pond you can sometimes see insects
perched there water boatmen or
backswimmers they skit along the surface
apparently oblivious to the depths below
or the Great Heights above for such
insects it appears that the water
surface is their home and they are
confined to it separate to the great
bulk above
and perhaps some scientists wonder the
same is true of us as for the insects on
the surface of the pond in
three-dimensional space so for us living
on a brain embedded within higher
dimensional space for as well as the
fundamental two-dimensional M2 brains M
Theory also predicts five-dimensional M5
brains when wrapped around both the
small extra 11th dimension of M Theory
and one of the small dimensions of
string theory some physicists have
speculated that these five-dimensional
brains could become three-dimensional
and large enough to fill the universe
and so perhaps they say we live on such
a brain embedded within a higher
dimensional space and the
electromagnetic weak and strong forces
that make up the standard model of
particle physics are fluctuations which
spread out along the brain confined to
its surface as ripples are confined to
the surface of a pond so waves on a
brain would be confined to the surface
of this three-dimensional brain the
words to be true the one exception would
be gravity gravity it seems is the most
universal of forces and it follows from
the equations that gravity is not and
can never be confined to the surface of
a brain its Force lines spread out not
just within but also away from the brain
it is this that provides one possible
explanation for either gravitational
force is so much weaker than all the
other forces with just your little
finger and its electromagnetic nerve
impulses you can pick up pen against the
gravitational pull of the entire Earth
all six billion trillion tons of it
acting together to pull the pen
downwards
why what makes gravity so much weaker
than the other forces perhaps this is
because our universe resides on a brain
inside a 10-dimensional space-time and
while the strong weak and
electromagnetic force lines remain
within the brain the gravitational force
lines spread out in additional
Dimensions thus reducing their potency
our cosmology only a fraction of the
truth of Heaven and Earth
and that is not the only Road physicists
and philosophers have gone down when
exploring the brain world
brains on the possibility of two
colliding brains also appear in
cosmological scenarios for the early
Universe in the idea of brain inflation
the enormous tensions and energies
associated with brains would have been
responsible for driving a period of
enormously rapid accelerated expansion
in the early universe
in this scenario the motion of a brain
through an extra dimensional bulk would
have been responsible for generating the
early acceleration of the universe We
Believe occurred in another scenario
called the equipirotic scenario in the
far past another brain would have
traveled towards our brain colliding
through and past it the legacy of this
Collision would be a series of small
deformations on the surface of our brain
which would subsequently grow under
Gravity to the cosmic superstructures
galaxies and clusters of galaxies which
we observe today
and so the possible ramifications of
living on a brain are intriguing but why
imagine exotic and speculative higher
dimensional cosmologies unless we have
any reason to think that they could
possibly be correct that these Notions
of brains and M Theory and actually make
any sense in the first place
[Music]
there is one ordeal all theoretical
physicists face at some point a thick
envelope arrives containing a neatly
printed book The accompanying letter
explains since retirement I have been
developing a new theory of Nature and I
think I have found some errors Einstein
made perhaps you would be so kind to
take a look
the manuscript will be in paoli's phrase
not even wrong instead the concepts will
be undefined the sentences will not
follow from one another as ill-defined
equation follows ill-defined equation to
an expert in theoretical physics the
manuscript is clearly nonsense even if
to an outsider one complicated equation
looks very much like another complicated
equation and so this question lingers on
behind every new development is
something similar true of M Theory is it
not even wrong
there are two Notions of correctness in
play here the first is the question of
whether M Theory is a true theory of our
world if we look at the Universe on the
deepest possible scales if we look to
smaller and smaller distances higher and
higher energies will M Theory be the
ultimate theory of our existence our
String Theory M Theory and brains
included as part of the same great
painting that features Newton's laws of
gravity Maxwell's laws of
electromagnetism the special and general
theories of Relativity and the standard
model of particle physics
are they
true
theoretical physics is hard at the best
of times even when operating together
with experimental evidence and this is a
problem for the ideas of string theory
and brains and other theories of quantum
gravity tread and especially lonely path
a path beyond the direct reach of
experiment for there is absolutely zero
direct experimental evidence for m
or string theory
direct experimental evidence would
require us as a species either to devise
or build large experiments and large
colliders which can determine the truth
about this universe and for theories of
quantum gravity this is a very hard task
to put this challenge in perspective the
Large Hadron Collider reaches energies
that are smaller than those required to
test the scales of quantum gravity by a
factor of one hundred thousand billion
to build an equivalent collider that
could reach energies at the quantum
gravity scale using the same technology
a similar set of magnets running the
entire way around the earth's equator
would be hopelessly inadequate one would
instead need a similar circular collider
around the Sun somewhere between Mercury
and Venus which is not going to happen
anytime soon
but there is a second notion of
correctness still hard to achieve but
not quite as hard as a solar system
spanning collider this is the notion of
mathematical correctness of internal
consistency how do we test that our
equations actually make sense
to a non-scientist trying to follow
debates about the frontiers of
theoretical physics these discussions
can sometimes sound like a Pokemon
battle with Scientists throwing ideas at
each other perturbative finiteness
dualities or background Independence who
is right either both or no one it is
very hard to tell in principle one may
think this question is easily answered
by reading someone's papers just go and
look and see if what they say makes
sense but in practice this is not so
straightforward understanding someone
else's new ideas takes time how can we
tell apart a wrong idea from one we
simply have not grasped yet or
alternatively how can we tell for sure
that an idea or theory is internally
consistent and so above all in the
absence of any experimental data or even
the possibility of it how can we ever
prove whether brains hidden dimensions
and M Theory are right or wrong thus M
Theory ultimately represent a fresh
example of Paulie's brutal put down an
untestable not even right not even wrong
Rabbit Hole of elegant equations
or is
there another way
[Music]
short distance from the never sleeping
city of New York lies the quiet college
town of Princeton and at the edge of
this famous campus lies The Institute
for advanced study secluded amongst the
woods
the professors of the institute for
advanced study do not need to teach
undergraduates or turn up to practical
classes to show clumsy students how to
use an oscilloscope
instead they are paid to think deep
thoughts
Robert Oppenheimer led the institute at
one time Freeman Dyson was another
faculty member but one of the very first
hires was the most famous Albert
Einstein although his spell there in the
latter part of his career was not his
most productive error as he struggled in
vain to find a unified theory of all
physics
today one of the most preeminent
thinkers there is the Argentinian
physicist Juan malda Cena quiet and
softly spoken there are many other
physicists who are Brasher or louder
phew a deeper and so it was in 1997 that
malda Cena buried in profound thought on
the physics of brains introduced a
striking new idea whereas M Theory seems
to have been named with an eye for the
attention it may bring this idea had a
far more humble moniker the ads CFT
correspondence
[Music]
this correspondence is probably the most
important theoretical idea to have
emerged from string theory in the last
30 years for it leads to a profound
re-evaluation of what gravity means and
also for the dimension of space means
malusena's remarkable Insight had
originated from thinking about what
physics would look like to a
hypothetical Observer moving extremely
close to a brain there were he argued
two possible ways of thinking about this
in the first he imagined life on the
brain looking at all the physics in
terms of fluctuations of the surface of
the brain physics if you like perceived
by the water boatman on the surface of
the pond and how these fluctuations
interacted with themselves and each
other in the second he imagined the
brain as a gravitational object within a
larger space time with the description
now all governed by the higher
dimensional theory of gravity physics
viewed by a higher dimensional external
Observer peering down at the surface of
the pond malda Cena's key Insight was
that while the actual physics had to be
ultimately the same these two different
observers would use very different
equations to develop these same physics
The Observers living on the brain would
describe these physics using a
non-gravitational theory a theory
analogous to those used to describe the
standard model the second Observer the
person peering close to the surface of
the pond is the external one in the bulk
this Observer sees the brain as a
gravitational object within space-time
and describes all of the physics near it
using a gravitational Theory a theory
which uses all of the spatial dimensions
of the brain itself but with one extra
spatial Dimension corresponding to the
vertical Direction perpendicular to the
surface of the brain maldoseena realized
that as these two theories describe the
same physics they must always give
identical answers even though the
descriptions of the two different
observers appeared very different there
was only one physical system and so the
results they gave must be the same
whatever the process for any physical
quantity one could compute in this
system there would be two different ways
to obtain the answer the first using the
theory of the first Observer similar to
those used to describe the strong force
within the standard model while the
second was a purely gravitational Theory
involving an extra dimension of space
perhaps malda Cena dared to dream it was
because these apparently different
descriptions were actually the same
theory in the terminology of physics the
two accounts were dual to one another
any calculation you could do in one you
could also do in the other
famously the Rosetta Stone allowed
Egyptian hieroglyphics to be deciphered
through the knowledge that the
information on the stone was the same in
all three of the languages used a
duality is like a scientific version of
the Rosetta Stone where exactly the same
information is present except presented
in different languages
here is one quantity computed with this
Theory a product of a heroic calculation
to levels of accuracy that go beyond any
of those achieved within the standard
model of particle physics if you are
asked to write down a random fraction
you would not be writing down these
there is no way you could write down
this expression by chance this
expression arose as a result of the
calculation in physics as perceived by
The Observer living on the brain looking
at the brain as a surface under tension
which fluctuates although in this case
the surface is a four-dimensional
hypersurface according to maldosena's
Duality this calculation should be
precisely and totally equivalent to a
calculation done in a five-dimensional
gravitational Theory and this
calculation has also been done exactly
the same all the complicated structure
of the first calculation worked out in
the four-dimensional theory for those
living on the brain is reproduced by the
second calculation done in a
five-dimensional gravity views the brain
as a gravitational object inside a
higher dimensional space-time
but what did this all mean
to understand this we must first
understand something about one general
property of quantum theories
some theories are more Quantum than
others
but some descriptions of physics
classical physics works extremely well
to describe how gravity affects a ball
thrown in the air we do not need to use
quantum mechanics although Quantum
effects are there they are so utterly
tiny that we can entirely neglect them
near a black hole Singularity Quantum
effects May matter in gravity but for
most purposes they are minuscule but for
other theories the quantum nature of the
system is crucial to everything the
physicists trying to understand the
details of the strong force inside the
standard model of particle physics the
quantum effects are always large
and this was the surprise for a pivotal
feature of malda Cena's Duality was the
equivalence the sameness between a
gravitational Theory and five dimensions
and a non-gravitational theory in four
dimensions it was a shocking claim that
initially appeared to physicists as
complete nonsense a gravity theory in
five Dimensions being the same as a
non-gravitational theory in four
dimensions it made no sense
but this was the key the fact that on
first appearance the claim was bizarre
and obviously wrong is what made its
truth so profound
ever since it was first proposed the
evidence formaldehner's bold conjecture
about the physics of brains the ads CFT
correspondence has piled up and this
evidence has shown again and again that
brains in string theory are
mathematically and theoretically
consistent even if we still don't know
whether they relate to the real world
whatever our initial skepticism whatever
our initial surprise it seems that at
least this Duality is on a mathematical
level
true radically different theories can in
fact carry the same information in
different languages
there was no way that this could have
been chance clearly manifestly there was
a deeper structure a deeper consistent
structure that explained these
mathematical connections very different
starting points very different
calculations But ultimately the same
answer and most importantly for our
understanding of the world this could
only happen if the brains of string
theory were real consistent objects
of course where the M Theory is
ultimately the consistent theory of our
world we do not know
yet
but we do know enough to say that it is
a consistent theory of something deep
ideas lurk behind the symbols
space
the final frontier
not so in the world of physics but will
the drive to penetrate the ever more
fundamental parts of physics through
atoms through nuclei through subatomic
particles and the standard model down to
the mysterious realm of quantum gravity
will this lead us to the fabled final
frontier or are the explanations endless
do they continue to Cascade onwards
further and deeper getting smaller and
more fundamental forever and ever
perhaps not perhaps the zooming stops
with tiny quantum mechanical strings and
brains at the heart of everything
we do not as yet
no what we can say now though is that
the ideas of brains of dualities of a
map of theories linked together into an
overall M Theory R mathematically
consistent
and just perhaps this foreshadows
physical correctness
as well
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think thanks for watching and
we'll see you
thank you